this is the way the Constitution was set
up by reading the Federalist Papers they
were very preoccupied with this and
because they were concerned about the
fact that the economic system placed the
money and property into the hands of a
few
they knew that those who didn't have it
would want to get it and so in addition
to the things you were talking about by
limiting voting participation in
government they continuously mentioned
the fact that the government must have
in it flaws
it must have flaws so it cannot work
efficiently it cannot respond to any
popular will might come along John Jay
and his whose first Chief Justice said
it 90 grooving the consensus in the
early years among those who were in
power those who own the country ought to
run it the world is governed by very
different percentages from what is
imagined by those who are not behind the
scenes and what I found standing behind
these individuals I believe our Lord
large corporations large foundations a
series of research institutes a series
of policy discussion groups that make it
so that a David Rockefeller is not
merely an individual but is in fact
constantly involved whether it's with a
bank or his foundation or policy
discussion group like the Council on
Foreign Relations and then one begins to
see that there's an ongoing
institutional structure and so that even
then when David Rockefeller retires you
see that the people that now run Chase
Manhattan Bank that now are the
directors of the Council on Foreign
Relations continue to be the people that
run the country
Clinton sits on the White House seat
while many work to ensure his defeat but
only few know that he's on the third row
of the American power elite on this
alternative views were going to take a
look at the American power structure
particularly as it relates to successive
presidential elections and
administrations
one of our most popular programs the
most mind-boggling mind opening programs
was one we did was number 269 it was
about the American power structure and
it really opens minds of a lot of people
to how the Americans economic and
political system works well we're going
to look at the Clinton administration
and see how it differs if at all from
those of the previous Republican
administrations and Jimmy Carter's
administration as far as where the prime
decision-makers come from its clinton
any different from anybody else or is a
really a change like the american people
thought they were voting for it Warren
Christopher is Secretary of State a
longtime member of the power elite he
was an attorney for a significant law
firm and he represented Exxon in a
pollution case he helped EF Hutton
regarding a cheque floating scheme and
lobbied for European chemical
conglomerate he served on the board of
Lockheed in Southern Cal Edison he lied
about not knowing about US military
intelligence spying on domestic
dissidents and he helped Clinton pick
Gore as his vice presidential running
mate
Roger Altman is Deputy Secretary of
Treasury he's an investment banker vice
chair of Blackstone Group which is
one-fifth owned by Nikko securities a
Japanese outfit specializing in mergers
and acquisitions particularly by foreign
corporations he brokered several of the
biggest acquisitions by Japanese firms
including CBS records and Columbia
Records he oversaw the Blackstone fund
that financed leveraged buyouts he also
was a Treasury official under Carter and
he helped to manage the federal bailout
of Chrysler he was a member of the
Council on Foreign Relations along with
les aspin the first secretary of defense
Lloyd Cutler was the replacement for the
president's legal adviser he's from a
prominent Washington law firm have
member of the CFR the Trilateral
Commission and the Bilderbergers you
know that Clinton was in trouble if he
had to haul in a heavy from the power
elite like Lloyd Cutler Anthony Lake
National Security Adviser had a high
position in the Carter Administration
and is also a member of the Council on
Foreign Relations
along with strobe Talbott Deputy
Secretary of State who was brought in
when Christopher got too old and too
ugly
Zoe Baird was Clinton's first choice for
attorney general
she belongs to none of these elite
organizations but she's a protege of
Lloyd Cutler who is she was employed by
General Electric and a longtime by Aetna
life during which time she worked for
several legal reforms which would help
corporations and hurt individuals
Jeffrey Garten holds the Commerce
Department's top trade position see a
man of the people he's a partner of the
Blackstone Group an investment bank
along with Robert Altman he's also
remembers the CFR Henry Cisneros used to
be a man of the people working for the
interests of poor Latinos and migrant
workers but then he became a lobbyist
for corporate interests he's a member of
the CFR and Clinton's conservative
Democratic Leadership Council Bobby
Inman who was Clinton's first choice for
the replacement for Secretary of Defense
is also from the Council on Foreign
Relations but Bobby decided to stay home
and enjoy life instead of going to
Washington as Donna shillelagh did the
secretary of Department of Health and
Human Services she has a Wall Street
background
she was also Chancellor of University of
Wisconsin where she favored affirmative
action and multicultural education but
she also tried to prohibit free speech
on campus Vice President Al Gore has
only recently received the stamp of
approval from the CFR David Gergen has
been there a while now he's replacement
press secretary and he held the same
position under Ronald Reagan
Madeleine Albright is a member of the
CFR which is traditional for ambassadors
to the UN she strongly supports the UN
as a medium to advance US interests
especially as global policeman here's an
appointment that really shows how things
work Tarullo has a top trade position in
the State Department but he was partner
in the New York law firm that
represented the Mexican government
during NAFTA negotiations james woolsey
as a member of the Council on Foreign
Relations that's nothing new all the
heads of the CIA have been a member of
that elite organization according to
progressive magazine he feels at home in
the extreme right wings of both the
Democratic and Republican parties here's
a good example of another way the
Council on Foreign Relations works
through the power elite retired General
John Vesey was sent as a special envoy
to Vietnam for M IAS it was just a
one-time job not a permanent position
here's a man who's had his head in the
trough for many years
Lloyd Bentsen supported all the Reagan
Bush tax bills and other Reaganomics
bills he's received praise and
assistance from top corporate lobbyists
and trade groups got millions of dollars
from PACs he also was involved in a
failed SNL which had mafia connections
although he's not a member of the
Council on Foreign Relations he has
attended a Bilderberger meeting he'll
talk more about these organizations a
CFR and the Bilderbergers later in the
program when Thomas Pickering was
ambassador to El Salvador he secretly
helped raise over 1 million dollars for
the Contras although is illegal here's
the king of sleaze Ron Brown he was a
lobbyist for Washington law firm he
lobbied for Haitian dictator baby doc
Duvalier and that nefarious bank BCCI
plus many Japanese companies he's
offered to recuse himself from cases
with old clients for only one year
stories abound about his using his
positions as head of the
Democratic National Committee in the law
firm to enrich himself and the Democrats
James Jones ambassador Mexico is perfect
example on how the system works he was
head of a Council on Foreign Relations
Study Group about NAFTA and then he was
appointed ambassador to Mexico Mickey
Kantor is a Trade Representative another
DC lawyer and lobbyist he represented
Philip Morris Occidental Petroleum
Martin Marietta Arco and many others he
lobbied for Occidental to drill off the
Pacific Palisades Shore Leon Panetta is
a deficit Hawk Frank Weisner the
prospective Undersecretary of defense
for policy this is a good example of how
things really don't change much he's a
member of the Council on Foreign
Relations and he also was a bush top
official being the former Undersecretary
of State for international security
affairs Robert E Reuben National
Economic Council Chairman is another
investment banker co-director of Goldman
Sachs and company he's worth a hundred
and thirty million himself he fought
banking reform defends speculation and
leveraged buyouts and for the last ten
years was said that he promoted and
defended the most destructive practices
of Wall Street Alice Rivlin
the budget director is another CFR
member as is Laura Tyson even though
she's not a mainstream free trade
economist she does believe in government
supports promotion of industries samuel
berger is deputy national security
adviser in addition to being a member of
the CFR he's a lawyer with an elite
washington law firm and one of Toyotas
chief lobbyists a fellow member of the
CFR bruce babbitt the secretary of
interior is praised by citizens
organization but he's also a member of
the conservative Democratic Leadership
Council bill clinton was co-founder and
chairman of the
McCready Leadership Council whose goal
was to wrest control of the Democratic
Party from the Liberals and make the
party more conservative this he has done
so we haven't really received much
change under Clinton his appointments
are still the same ol elites and the
same old lobbyists as a matter of fact
The Wall Street Journal said the only
real difference between these lobbyists
advising the Clinton transition team and
their Republican predecessors during the
Reagan Bush administration's is that the
Democrats are making a greater effort to
be discreet about their role in light of
mr. Clinton's criticism of lobbyists
during the campaign one of the most
prominent modern American political
scientists Harold Lasswell who's a
leading figure in communications and
such things he wrote the article on
propaganda in the international
encyclopedia of social sciences which
was published in 1933 and in it he says
that we should not succumb the
Democratic dogmatism about men being the
best judges of their own interests they
are not the best judges are the elites
us smart guys the cool observers and we
must therefore be ensured the means to
impose our will for the common good of
course I wrote a little speech he gave a
speech right before I left Congress and
I said I don't think the members of
Congress would really know how little
effect they have in controlling things
right it is and that means that the
Congress that itself doesn't have much
control the people doesn't have much
they don't have much to say about it
either the control of overall policy is
really in the hands of a very small
number of people who control all the
administration's all the appointments to
cabinets and certainly all the
appointments to the Federal Reserve
but it might be my
the bedrock organization of the American
power structure particularly in
relationship to the political sphere is
the Council on Foreign Relations we'll
see how our leaders and policy originate
within the CFR it's mainly the New York
Wall Street bankers lawyers who control
the steering and advisory committees of
it what they have done over the years is
basically to do several things first set
u.s. foreign policy second determine
what is acceptable in the way of
policies and what is discussable in the
proper governmental circles you've also
been very important in the determining
consensus and eliciting a consensus from
the upper class not only just the
immediate post-war policy but also the
extended post-war policy including the
policy toward Vietnam Guatemala and Cuba
the International Monetary Fund the
World Bank these ideas were hatched from
the Council of Foreign Relations and
accepted by the US government some of
these were the u.s. entry into World War
two determining u.s. world area of
interest the decision to drop the atomic
bomb the Marshall Plan United Nations
International Monetary Fund and the
World Bank
these ideas were all hatched in the
Council on Foreign Relations the
origination of NATO the post-war policy
toward Soviet Union China Germany and
South Africa the decision to end the
Vietnam War was decided in the CFR the
conduct of the Cuban Missile Crisis was
determined by CFR people when the
government would have various special
advisers most of these people would be
from the Council of Foreign Relations
the Nixon administration is a good
example because in it there were 110
Council on Foreign Relations members
participating as far as the CFR itself
in one year alone 1965 of the 1,400
people in the organization 176 were
currently in government and 400 more
previously let's look at previous
administrations you look at the State
Department there were six men since
well from the Eisenhower administration
to the present six men have been
Secretary of State all of them had been
on the Council of Foreign Relations one
of them was on the trilateral commission
and forward bilderbergers Secretary of
Defense there were eight men six from
the Council of Foreign Relations two
were bilderbergers two from the
trilateral commission and on and on like
this even the CIA the seven directors of
the CIA five were from the collar
Foreign Relations one was a Bilderberger
and one of the persons who was the head
of the CIA actually helped to establish
the Bilderberg organization and the
National Security Adviser they're nine
men eight from the Council of Foreign
Relations six are bilderbergers and one
also from the trilateral commission
we've taken a look previously at the
Clinton cabinet and the members of the
Council on Foreign Relations here are
some of the other positions that are
occupied by CFR people there are the
high positions in the State Department
and ambassadors to various countries
here are some other people who are in
the Defense Department who are members
of the CFR note that the supreme Allied
commanders and the superintendent's of
the Military Academy at West Point have
all come from the CFR and look at the
businessmen who our members of the
organization these are all people who
held high positions in the oil industry
and some of the other positions in
industry notice also that there are some
familiar names that have been in high
government positions in previous
administrations particularly notice how
pervasive the CFR membership is in the
elite banks of the United States this is
very significant because it is control
of the banks which gives control over so
many of the other major corporations in
the United States
take a look at the media members of the
Council on Foreign Relations every
Network anchor except one is a member of
the CFR note that all these people are
members of the organization they never
report on it it's interesting to hear
the perspective of William Dom Hoff he
has a professor who has written the most
extensively than any other American
about power in the United States he
wrote the book who rules America who
rules America now and many others you
have to look at where the
decision-makers come from see if the
prime decision-makers come from this
ruling class or the people who this
ruling class is selected right where I
think that that's another very useful
way of understanding about power because
it's the most visible to us that is we
can watch people we may we right now are
not we don't know what's being talked
about in the set usually at the National
Security Council or in the private
meetings in the White House but we sure
do know who's there and to give you an
example if we take the Secretary of
Treasury as a important position and we
look at a few of them for instance under
Kennedy who ran on a platform of getting
the country moving again we've got to
get beyond this stodgy Republican
establishment so on and yet when he was
elected the person he put in charge of
Treasury was a man named C Douglas Dylan
from a man were several hundreds of
billions of dollars who from a major
investment house in in New York when we
jump to Jimmy Carter who was our
populist and Hamilton Jordan assured us
that we were going to see new faces in
fact the person that we got is our
Secretary of Treasury was a man named W
Michael Blumenthal who was the head of
Bendix corporation a trustee of the
Council on Foreign Relations a trustee
of the committee for Economic
Development
trustee of Princeton University and a
member of the Trilateral Commission and
he becomes our Secretary of Treasury now
Ronald Reagan comes in and he's going to
get rid of the mess in Washington from a
neoconservative perspective but our
Secretary of Treasury is a man named
Donald Regan I was it was his first
Secretary of Treasury as you know and
and Donald Regan was from Merrill Lynch
he was a member of the Council on
Foreign Relations he was a trustee of
the committee for economic development
he was a trustee of the Business
Roundtable and what I'm saying of course
with those examples is that when we look
at the cabinet level appointments of the
past 40 years at the least but we could
go back further but if we look at the
last 40 years that whether it's a
Republican or a Democrat whether it's a
populist or a neoconservative whatever
particular ticket they run on or
ideology they run on in order to attract
a coalition of voters when they turn to
the question of governing when they turn
to the question of how are they going to
implement a set of policies they do as
your question suggests they turn to the
same group of people the Council on
Foreign Relations is controlled by folks
of high stations they say who's
respectable and Jews who's electable but
we don't know of these covert
paginations walter Lippmann who was the
Dean of American journalists wrote about
what he called the manufacturer of
consent that's where that phrase comes
from and he said that the manufacturer
of consent has become a self-conscious
art and a regular organ of popular
government in a revolution in the
practice of democracy and this he
thought was appropriate because the
common interests very largely elude
public opinion entirely and can be
managed only by a specialized class
whose personal interests reach beyond
the locality let's take a look at the
Bush administration was it any different
from the Carter or the Clinton no we see
that the top decision makers still or
members of the Council on Foreign
Relations the Trilateral Commission or
have attended
Bilderberg meetings
but as you've setup at the top they're
all the same people the corporate
executives go to and from the government
they hold positions in the government
the people from the Trilateral
Commission and the Bilderbergers and all
they're all corporate people and they
have their relationships and interlocks
with the banks and with universities and
foundations and all that so to talk
about one so you're really talking about
one source of power instead of
corporation on one side and government
on the air because it's all one pot as
you say I think it's become one pot not
only that is you don't have any help I
say voting for a Democrat who may be a
little more critical of large
corporations but we know Democrats are
just as much in bed with big government
to here's a chart which shows the people
in the federal reserve system who are
from the CFR if you look at the members
of the Federal Reserve you find out that
they don't ask people like me to be on
the Federal Reserve even though I've had
experience on studying the issue and
been on the banking committee they ask
only the people who are casually
referred to as the insiders those from
Wall Street in the banking industry the
poll Volkers and the Alan Greenspan's of
the world they're on the inside they
know how to deal with the establishment
and they get these positions and
therefore it is a tremendous amount of
economic power falls in the hands of
what we call the Open Market Committee
the Federal Open Market Committee they
control from day to day the supply money
they become the legal Konnor fitters you
know if you and I had control of the
printing press we could do a lot a lot
of things you know self-serving that's
what happens when the politicians create
the central bank that get that to
control the money now this control of
central bank and the money goes on
regardless of which party is in power
right it never changes you know they
change a person here and there
but it's always the insiders it's always
from the same group so if you have a
Republican as president or the Democrats
they're going to get the same
appointments appointments never change
that this can be said about the
Secretary of State
in the Secretary of Defense and
Secretary of Treasury and in the Federal
Reserve Board members they all come from
the same group and even though I guess
naively I was hopeful that the same
group of individuals would not have as
much power under on under Ronald Reagan
so either side they're the same people
control it and you know Ronald Reagan
spoke sharply against the trilateral
commission but he was the first
president to host the trilateral
commission in the White House I mean
that's how blatant it is it says it's
the same group of people we've referred
several times to the trilateral
commission let's go back to an older
program where we talked in greater
detail about the organization again we
find David Rockefeller at the very
pinnacle of the trilateral commission
they described themselves as a private
North American European and Japanese
initiative on matters common concern
what they would like to do is fashion a
stable world order on the after the
fashion of the one produced after world
war ii by many of the same people and
certainly the same interests as
represented for instance in the Council
on Foreign Relations the kernel of the
idea for the trilateral commission arose
in the head of probably its mastermind
Sevigny Brzezinski who is now national
security adviser to President Carter
in 1970 talked about the need for
collaboration between these three areas
of the world and North America and
Western Europe the need for
collaboration to face certain problems
obstacles to the continued expansion of
the capitalist world order by July of
1973 the trilateral commission was
officially formed shortly after that
it's interesting to note they had
selected already now President Jimmy
Carter and Walter Mondale as mission up
commissioners they did this expressly
for the purpose of running them for high
office in the United States there were
certain meetings between David
Rockefeller and Jimmy Carter as early as
1971 in which David Rockefeller decided
that Carter would be the perfect person
to build their hopes on so Carter
Mondale and in the Republican camp
Elliot Richardson were all invited to be
commissioners with the hope that the at
least one of these people would be the
future president as it turns out of
course Carter has become president and
out of the 74 American commissioners
about 21 of them are now in the Carter
Administration Cyrus Vance Harold Brown
secretary of defense Michael Blumenthal
Secretary of Treasury C fred Bergsten
assistant secretary of treasury Warren
Christopher deputy Deputy Secretary of
State the list goes on and on Warren
Christopher Richard Cooper
Lucy Wilson Richard Holbrooke Anthony
Lake Andrew Young surprisingly they're
convinced that there is too much
Democratic participation
allowed that there's too much it's
making economic planning of the world
capitalist system very difficult for
them so one of their domestic goals is
to centralize economic planning the
governability of democracy according to
Samuel Huntington who is influential
person in this group depends upon an
expansion of capital and continued
accumulation which is virtually
impossible if the people run the system
they think that on the lead is much
better equipped to make decisions which
maximize profits what's the crisis of
democracy that they're concerned with in
all of the democratic societies well the
crisis is that during the 1960's large
groups of people who are normally
passive and apathetic began to try to
enter the political arena to press their
demands and that's a crisis which has to
be overcome the naive might call that
democracy but that's because they don't
understand the sophisticated understand
that that's a crisis of democracy the
American spokesmen again Samuel
Huntington wrote in his report that
Harry Truman had been able to govern the
country with the cooperation of a
relatively small number of Wall Street
lawyers and bankers in those days there
was no crisis of democracy things were
working just right but in the 1960s you
got all this turmoil I mean young people
and women
the labor and all kinds of weird people
who were supposed to be sitting quietly
in the corners began to get involved and
caused this crisis I mean the same
crisis that arose in the 17th century
and there repeatedly arises when people
begin to try to take advantage of the
formal opportunities that exist among
the terrible things that were happening
during the 60s causing this crisis they
said was that you had this group of
people who they called value-oriented
intellectuals people who are concerned
with things like truth and justice and
all that sort of nonsense and they're
opposed to the good guys the
technocratic and policy oriented
intellectuals they called the commissar
that ones who just do the job which had
these value-oriented intellectuals and
they were doing all sorts of horrible
things like under my D legitimizing the
institutions that are responsible for
the indoctrination of the young like
schools and universities remember this
is an internal discussion so they kind
of let their hair down there are general
proposal at the end of all of this these
lengthy and thoughtful discussions was
that what we need is more moderation in
democracy to mitigate the excess of
democracy and overcome the crisis in
plain terms what that means is that the
public has to be reduced to their proper
state of apathy and obedience and driven
from the public arena if democracy is to
survive and the appropriate sense with
the specialized class you know the cool
observers smart guys the technocratic
and policy are an intellectuals doing
our job in the interests of the people
who have real power
what Huntington has realized is that the
party system it can be used very
effectively to reduce participation in
in his words
apathy is very functional and the party
system can be used in the sense as a
rubber stamp for policies that are made
elsewhere in the system I think it's
important to note that all of these
groups that we're talking about have as
their ideal the stabilization of the
status quo the management of the system
from concern with management of the very
top from the very top of the world
capitalist economic order to
domestically the management of the
polity here in the United States and
that is clearly their main goal one way
that this is be achieved will have to be
through restrictions on the press media
and they've called for restoration of
the law of libel for the press which
people associated with the media in the
press know that that could be a very
dangerous kind of weapon by the
government against freedom of expression
the liberals as in the trilateral
commission or in fact agree they in the
same study they say that the media
threatened government authority by their
adversarial stance and they've got to be
curbed
if they can't curb themselves the
government is going to move in the curve
curb them part of the policy is to have
a kind of consensus the coordination
between five or six major industrial
powers in the world they see the need
not only for it well they they recognize
there's a great deal of interdependence
now they see the need for for much more
cooperation coordination than there's
been in the past so they think that five
or six key industrial states getting
together can in turn dominate the major
third-world countries these countries of
course supply
cheap resources cheap labor which are
necessary for the industrialized
countries they recognized that the
demands in these third-world countries
are increasing for a greater share of
the pie so they advocate giving a
certain degree of power control and a
bit larger piece of the pie to certain
clientele elites within third-world
countries in this way then major
industrial powers can control elite in
third world countries which in turn
supplied liberally with taxpayer-funded
military hardware would be able to
subjugate their own population it's our
conclusion about the trilateral
commission they described themselves
they say that they want a kind of
concentric circle of decision-making and
this would involve these few major
industrial states and not wide
participation from these industrial
states would be participation by the
economic elites such as David
Rockefeller of course directing that
would be the core the central aspect of
just concentric circle they talk about
just outside that they would involve to
a lesser extent industrializing
countries the more advanced third world
countries and beyond that would be a
circle of these world organizations like
the World Bank IMF and other
international agencies which would
establish the record of the regulations
by which third world countries
and all other industrialized countries
would be regulated the the hope is of
course to coordinate to stabilize and to
reduce competition Clinton plays on the
sax and he sings he says he's in control
of things he'll bleed to nil Beller but
as Dave Rockefeller who really pulls the
strings what these organizations do is
they legitimate these people as
fair-minded expert you see the
interesting thing about politics in
America in terms of policies as opposed
to electing individuals is that the
political organizations of the ruling
class are not called political now this
seemed unfazed that's an irony yeah in a
way that is all the groups in America
that are called nonpartisan bipartisan
non-political that's the political
organizations of the ruling class in
America you see if you go out and say I
don't understand how you can talk about
a ruling class there's a Democrats over
here there's a Republicans over here
that's politics isn't it no that's just
society which individuals will fill
offices politics in the important sense
of of which policies we all agree are
makes sense that happens in
non-political organization so when the
committee for Economic Development puts
out a statement it says the committee
for economic development a nonpartisan
group of business people today suggested
we alter the Social Security system in
the following way and then they say look
some of our members are Democrats some
of our members are Republican we're
trying to get something that's good for
all of America we're trying to transcend
politics we're trying to do something
that's that's in the national interest
now once you say yeah that's fair we got
to get beyond this fight between
Republicans and Democrats they're there
they're people that have been run an
organization their success in America
and then we identify with them because
of their high status and because they're
part of this fair-minded organization
academic experts from Harvard have
helped them and from Yale and who are we
you know argue with somebody from
Harvard and Yale plus a successful
business leader and that's what we call
legitimation in my mind of
of their policy this also involves
experts in America not just
multimillionaires and corporate
executives but very important experts
are part of this power elite that we're
talking about as well and what I'm then
saying is that that councils on Foreign
Relations committees for economic
development so on actually have
basically a monopoly of the respectable
expertise in the United States the
people that are sound and sensible these
are all in close respect I Kissinger
being wanted and that's exactly where
I'm headed is to Henry Kissinger we look
at the career of Henry Kissinger we
might say well only in America in one
way yes because here is a person who's a
escapee from from Nazi Germany who by
going to school here by doing well at
Harvard we could say look at him he's
been very important and he had but here
is the other part of Kissinger career
that's so important while he was at
Harvard he was seen by a man named
McGeorge Bundy who was the Dean of the
Faculty of the head of the faculty and
from a prominent Boston family is father
is a corporation lawyer in other words
he's a well-to-do person that happened
to be in the academic world and he
called his friends at the Council on
Foreign Relations and he said you know
this guy Kissinger is a bright young guy
and he could really be useful in some of
the discussion groups and so Kissinger
was invited to be in these discussion
groups and Nelson Rockefeller was really
taken with Kissinger and he basically
then hired him to write things for him
and to write things for panels of
experts that the Rockefeller set up well
in the late 60s the interesting thing is
that of course that Richard Nixon
appointed Kissinger as his foreign
policy adviser now the first reason
that's interesting is that supposedly
Nixon and kisses me that Nixon
Rockefeller were so different they had
all their political conflict and yet
Nixon was perfectly willing to hire what
seemed to be quotes Nelson Rockefellers
but beyond that the interesting thing is
that two years after the election at a
point when Kissinger star was quite high
Hubert Humphrey was interviewed was
taught they were talking about what he
would have done if he was president he
said well it's funny he said one of the
things I was going to do was a point
Henry Kissinger he had talked to Henry
Kissinger before the election saying if
I'm elected will you be my foreign
policy adviser my point is of course
whether we get Nixon or whether we get
Humphrey there was one thing we were
sure we were going to get and that was
Kissinger it was the Rockefeller man
yeah but basically by that time of
course he's known to many of these
corporate people his expertise is very
useful to them
he's been legitimated through being part
of these organizations like the council
but then let's take it down to what I
think's also interesting in terms of
continuity of a power structure take it
down to the early 1980s Ronald Reagan
well Reagan in part ran on a platform
that was practically running against
Henry Kissinger one of the things the
very conservative Republicans do not
like is what they call the eastern
establishment and one of their favorite
pet peeves with an Eastern establishment
is the Council on Foreign Relations and
one part of that is Henry Kissinger well
what do we end up with within a year or
two we have Henry Kissinger as head of
the President's Commission on Central
America in other words Ronald Reagan
also then hires Henry Kissinger so when
you just trace the career of that man
you then see the continuity in the power
structure but at the same time we're
back to our earlier point about are we
just talking about individuals no we're
not because we have to understand that
Kissinger first was at a very important
institution called Harvard which is one
of the main reservoirs of expertise as
well as a place for upward mobility
where experts are seen by members of the
ruling class whether they're McGeorge
Bundy or whether they're trustees the
University then he went to the Council
on Foreign Relations where as part of a
discussion group of 20 or 30 people from
all over the country people from the CIA
people from the State Department people
from corporations people
law firms other academic experts and in
that situation he they say this person
sees the world the way we do and he has
information that's that's very useful to
us and so it's this institutional
setting that he's moved through that
brings him into other power structure
let's look now at the Reagan
administration to see if it also is
dominated by members of these elite
organizations well all these people
listed now are members of the Council on
Foreign Relations some of them also
Bilderbergers and members of the
trilateral commission we see a
continuing interest in the dominance of
certain sections of the American
executive department defense Treasury
Commerce the CIA and of course
particularly the State Department we
must remember when considering this list
as well as others we've looked at that
the Council on Foreign Relations is a
tiny organization less than 2,000 people
but each member approved by David
Rockefeller and a handful or less of his
friends should we point out though that
these people are more conservative than
their elite colleagues in the Carter
Administration there's a shadow on the
do the words that I bought in
where the business
I wanna I wanna hear somebody
they can be counted on the
Indonesia but then
let's look at the men who are really in
the shadows the Bilderberg organization
well the first meeting was in 1954 at
the Bilderberg Hotel and Holland that's
how they got their name who are they
well David Rockefeller is the chairman
of the head man of the Bilderbergers
he's also head man of the Chase
Manhattan Bank of the council Foreign
Relations and of the trilateral
commission the participants are a mix of
the most powerful men of the
transnational oil sector of the world
economy the multinational banks and also
the important leaders of the world
political leaders and this is
supplemented by key congressmen military
leaders representatives from the
intelligence and police organizations
like CIA and Interpol the elite
foundations members of mass media and
the Rockefeller think tanks and the
elite universities these are people from
the NATO countries basically and they're
people like this from the US who meet
with their counterparts in three day
sessions three day meetings an extreme
secrecy with great security precautions
taken
now I say since 1954 this has been going
on and nothing has been in the
television television about it very very
little has been in any of the newspapers
now the right wing has been screaming
about it constantly what are these
people doing but the interesting thing
is not only do all these people most
powerful people in the world meeting
together but nobody knows what is
happening except a little bit here and
there we can find out they do discuss
working papers and various sorts like
the decline of American power or what to
do about the American dollars things
like this but basically we don't know
but there are a lot of very impressive
facts about this one is that several men
who were invited to attend the
Bilderberg meetings later became the
number one or number two men in their
government of their respective countries
like Gerald Ford Helmut Schmidt Nelson
Rockefeller Harold Wilson Edward Heath
and Walter Mondale in addition to that
there are a lot of people who used to be
powerful in the government who still
meet with the Bilderbergers and so you
find a continuation of people for
instance Dean Acheson Dean Rusk Henry
Kissinger is magnificent regime scheme
all these people Republican or
administer or Democratic administrations
it doesn't make any difference
they're all there with the Bilderbergers
the organization this is what might be
called a capitalist cartel basically and
these meetings are held in great secrecy
as I said they have roadblocks
bulletproof cars they had one meeting on
an island before they had the meeting
they moved everybody off the island they
had another one and another meeting in a
hotel where they moved everybody out of
the hotel brought in all new staff and
after having security checks on the new
staff they wouldn't let them leave the
hotel for the three days of the meeting
thing one important aspect of the
Bilderberg Group is probably that here
is the place where the rare consensus is
effected so that they can present a
world view that's pretty much the same
workout any any problems or rough spots
which they may have in the International
Organization President Roosevelt knew
how power was wielded in politics
nothing
happens by accident if it happens you
can bet it was planned that way
let's turn once again to Noam Chomsky
who tells us about 17th century English
revolution and the struggles of the
people against the lead control and the
attitudes of these elites toward true
democracy that was a multi-dimensional
affair with a civil war between the
supporters of the king and the
supporters of parliament but then a big
popular movement was against all of them
and didn't want and was trying to and
had a very populist radical Democratic
character to it
and was defeated the Democrats were
defeated within about 20 years by 1660
and you read their pamphlets they were
saying that we've lost the only question
now is who's slaves the poor shall be
king or Parliament many revolutions have
the same consequence
maybe all so far till one yet to come in
the course of that struggle there was a
great deal of concern over the fact that
the general population was gaining the
opportunity and even the idea of
becoming involved directly in shaping
their own affairs and that led to great
concerns John Locke wrote that day
laborers and tradesmen the spinsters and
dairymaids must be told what to believe
the greatest part cannot know and
therefore they must believe one of the
contemporary historians man named
Clement Walker wrote at the time that of
the deep concern of the liberal elements
we're talking about now over the fact
that these guys with their little
printing presses putting out pamphlets
and you know agitating and the army and
that sort of thing we're beginning to
reveal the mysteries of government and
he said if they do that they will make
people so curious and arrogant that they
will never
and humility enough to submit to a civil
rule that has to be stopped
and the same idea comes right up to the
modern period the class structure and
class nature of the United States now we
hear about middle class very frequently
is written a lot of things are studied
about the middle class and a lot of
things been written about the middle
class
you see frequently lower middle class
and lower but you don't see too much
written about upper class enough there's
a middle class there has to be an upper
right I think they're very definitely is
an upper class in the United States and
indeed that's been the starting point of
my research is to start with social
clubs exclusive private schools summer
resorts to start with what we can see if
we will but look to see these people as
a set of interacting and intermarrying a
set of families who have developed a
whole set of social institutions that
preserve their way of life once we have
located these various schools clubs
resorts retreats debutante balls then we
can understand the historical continuity
of social upper-class in America it's my
belief that about half a percent of
Americans are part of what I would call
a social upper-class and these people
owned about twenty to twenty five
percent of all the privately held wealth
in the United States that is if we took
all of your wealth which might be your
car your house your insurance policy if
we threw in your guitar everything we
took all of that wealth plus the stocks
and bonds and real estate in America it
would put all that in a big pile twenty
to twenty-five percent of all of that
one half of one percent of the people
have that in the United States and what
my thesis basically says is that those
people that have that 20 to 25 percent
of all the privately held wealth are not
mere individuals that are scattered here
and there and are kind of rare and don't
know each other but in fact they are are
closely knit they know each other they
see the world the same way they do
discuss with each other
the kinds of policies that they think
would further their way of life so in
that sense we then talk about them in
this more sociological abstracts sense
that they're not just families because
in fact there there are these ongoing
institutional kinds of structures and
they are structures that do matter when
we talk about whether a group is ruling
or not we have to look at three or four
indicators of power one of course is
we've taught we've hit upon when we
talked about wealth if a group is a
dominant group or a ruling group we
would expect them to have more of what
people value in a society and certainly
this upper social class we've been
talking about has more wealth it has
more income
it certainly has access to the best
education health care and so on so on
all the measures of who benefits I think
there's that shows that they are a
ruling class because we would all like
to be a lot richer we'd all like to be a
lot more secure in our economic
circumstance but I also think that we
can show that these people are a ruling
class when we look at the kinds of
policies that are implemented by the
federal government and these policies
range from subsidies for specific
corporations and industries tax breaks a
little shaving on regulations and so on
on up to more general policies policies
that I think basically benefit large
corporations as a group and that means
kinds of foreign policies that maximize
the possibility of investment overseas
policies at the domestic level that that
maximize the possibility of a tranquil
and happy and docile workforce numerous
kinds of policy the most important issue
is power is control in other words if
I'm going to make a few million dollars
left for a few years okay but I want to
keep my
my situation I want to keep the general
system running you John J and his whose
first Chief Justice said it 90 grooving
the consensus in the early years among
those who were in power those who own
the country ought to run it and that
means that the Congress that itself
doesn't have much control the people
doesn't have much they don't have much
to say about it either the control of
overall policy is really in the hands of
a very small number people who control
all the administration's all the
appointments to cabinets and certainly
all the appointments to the Federal
Reserve the world is governed by very
different percentages from what is
imagined by those who are not behind the
scenes and what I found standing behind
these individuals I believe our Lord
large corporations large foundations a
series of research institutes a series
of policy discussion groups that make it
so that a David Rockefeller is not
merely an individual but is in fact
constantly involved whether it's with a
bank or his foundation or policy
discussion group like the Council on
Foreign Relations and then one begins to
see that there's an ongoing
institutional structure and so that even
then when David Rockefeller retires you
see that the people that now run Chase
Manhattan Bank that now are the
directors of the Council on formulation
continue to be the people that run the
country you look at the State Department
there were six men since well from the
Eisenhower administration to the present
six men have been secretary of state all
of them had been on the Council of
Foreign Relations one of them was on the
Trilateral Commission and for rebuilding
breakers Secretary of Defense there were
eight men six from the Council of
Foreign Relations two were Bilderbergers
two from the trilateral commission and
on and on like this even the CIA the
seven directors of the CIA five were
from the caller reporting relations one
was a Bilderberg
and one of the persons who was the head
of the CIA actually helped to establish
the Bilderberg organization and the
National Security Adviser there nine men
eight from the Council of Foreign
Relations six are bilderbergers and one
also from the trilateral commission
Clinton sits on the White House seat
while many work to ensure his defeat but
only few know that he's on the third row
of the American power elite hour is a
word that Americans are just very
uncomfortable with now I must say that
we know it we know that there's the
other side of the tracks and there's the
people that live in the nice houses we
have all of these euphemisms that we use
for power structures and for social
classes I think they're very definitely
is an upper class in the United States
and indeed that's been the starting
point of my research if a group is a
dominant group or a ruling group we
would expect them to have more of what
people value in a society and certainly
this upper social class we've been
talking about has more wealth it has
more income
it certainly has access to the best
education health care and so on so on
all the measures of who benefits I think
that that shows that they are a ruling
class let's take a look at wealth and
income in the United States and see how
it's distributed in the late 1950s the
wealthiest 1% of the families held 80
percent of all publicly held stock and
ten years later 0.2 percent of American
spending units had 65 to 70 percent of
all public stock this means wealth and
how is the distribution of wealth in the
US well the richest two percent of US
citizens had wealth greater than the
u.s. gross national product in 1962 0.5%
of the consumer units had 22 percent and
2.5 percent had 61 percent of all
American wealth what about the
distribution of income well income is a
little bit different because wealth
produces income most of us work for in
come we don't have wealth or that much
of it so we see that in the income
distribution in 1968 the top 10% had 30%
of income the top 30% had 58 percent of
the income the bottom 40% had 15% and
the poorest 20% of us had 4% of the
income income is concentrated at the top
just like wealth is in the United States
during the reagan-bush era there was an
enormous re transfer of wealth and
income from the poor and the middle
class back up to the rich in 1959 the
top 4% of the families had the same as
the bottom 35% in income but in 1989 the
top 4% had the same as the bottom 51
percent that's Reaganomics at work the
big tax reform of 1986 was a significant
part of this redistribution of wealth
and income because if you add up to
$10,000 an income you had 11% cut in
your taxes but I'd only gave you an
extra $37 if you had between 20 and 30
thousand also 11% cut but that was only
$300 we'll look what happens when you
become wealthy two hundred thousand five
hundred thousand you got twenty seven
thousand six hundred in tax breaks
five hundred thousand to a million you
got eighty six thousand dollars in a tax
cut and for a million dollars or more of
income a thirty one percent decrease in
your taxes which gave you over a quarter
of a million dollars in tax cut this was
supposed to trickle down to the rest of
us but mainly was used for speculation
for building plants overseas or just for
plain old-fashioned enrichment
what does this mean concretely well that
one year when the wealthiest four
thousand families received four billion
dollars in income this was more than all
government spending to feed the poor
twice the amount of money used for ni
poverty programs and was more than all
federal money spent on education and
speaking of power those who have it
reaped the riches people sometimes call
our system socialism for the rich
capitalism for the poor other people
simply call it welfare for the rich I
compiled a list from several books which
specify just some of these special
treatments which the wealthy are able to
get from our system tax loopholes tax
exempt property interest free deposits
estimated nine hundred billion dollars a
year monopoly costs that means because
these big corporations are monopolies
they can gouge the consumers so they get
anywhere from a hundred to two hundred
thirty billion dollars a year and over
charges plus the loss of regular
production from forty to sixty billion
dollars the Interstate Commerce
Commission the Federal Maritime
Commission the Civil Aeronautics Board
they all are for business people the
timber growers they get a hundred
million a year farm subsidies ten
billion and 73 alone it's much more than
that by now
tax evasion cost the US Treasury
anywhere between twenty nine sixty seven
billion I've seen some people to say
it's as much as 200 billion
multinational corporations can deduct
from their US taxes the operating costs
of their foreign subsidiaries import
quarters and duties also cost the
American consumer anywhere from five to
seven billion dollars how about those
roads for the trucking industry or the
free radio and TV stations given away by
the FCC and you know they're
interest-free government deposits and
banks but the government must pay
interest to borrow money their export
subsidies the pentagon costs overruns my
gosh you know about that
and the welfare contracts - big
corporations we think that people are
welfare chiselers because they're
getting a few dollars a month well most
of that money goes to big corporations
for conducting the welfare programs you
know the government does the research
and gets the program going like NASA and
the nukes and all and then they turn it
over to the corporation's to get the
profits and tax money which goes to the
International Monetary Fund guarantees
the foreign loans to the banks American
tax money is going to be going to the
banks and the savings and loans for
bailouts for them you know tobacco will
kill you but the u.s. is supporting it
their export subsidies most of the
executive branch goes to help business
along with many agencies for the states
well how about taxes those investment
tax credits capital gains depletion
allowances accelerated depreciation low
or non-existent corporate tax profits
they don't pay the taxes you do folks
and those tax deductions travel country
clubs corporate lobbying and political
contributions are all deductible and how
about all the defense expenditures is
that welfare for the rich - socialism
for the rich capitalism for the poor but
as far as power is concerned control of
wealth is of prime importance and this
is done mainly through institutional
investors like banks and insurance
companies in an older alternative use
program professor Alice Levinsky
explained I think it's sort of war on
the lines of a pyramid scheme if you can
control a corporation by conjoin just a
small segment of its stock that's one
thing but if you have a bank which
through its trust departments has lots
of lots of stock and lots of companies
and you can centralize your control and
this is exactly what the Rockefellers as
well as I guess the other ten or twelve
wealthy mega wealthy families the United
States learn many years ago that you can
control the corporation's of the United
States
better more efficiently cheaper the
whole
bid by controlling a few financial
institutions these banks in turn and
these families in turn also form
alliances with other families and banks
and institutions throughout the United
States
Carnegie might have called rockefeller
record feller but his daughter Nancy
married Rockefeller the listing of what
Knowles says are some of the
corporations which the Rockefellers just
the Rockefellers alone not in Constance
with the mortgage or anybody else alone
which they have DuPont grace Corning
Glass Works Cummins engine these are
just few of Pittsburgh coke and chemical
during Milliken Field enterprises
mercantile stores Standard Oil of New
Jersey Mobil Oil Standard Oil of
California Standard Oil of Indiana
International Harvester inland steel
Marathon Oil Quaker Oats tweeting
Pittsburgh steel Freeport sulphur etc
etc go to another page stone and Webster
Federated Department Stores Walgreens
stores Marshall Field I'd like to have
one of those in my talk for Christmas
and plenty of others IBM Texaco ITT
Westinghouse Boeing Kodak International
Paper 3m sprayer and Xerox National Cash
Register national steel American Home
Products Fitzer hercules mark universal
oil products Penn Central TWA Eastern
Airlines Northwest Airlines JC Penney
consolidated Freight who let's see
Anaconda Corporation Consolidated Edison
ATT US Steel Monsanto General Foods
Chrysler Oakland Olin corporation
pan-american Colgate Palmolive Pete
burner worker and home insurance and
seer number the utilities con Edison is
Israel I guess it's reasonable to say
con Edison is controlled by Rockefellers
at one time the rockefeller institutions
also had 40% of the board of directors
of AT&T Rockies folks are king of the
hill they are controlling us still they
owned the big banks the mics and the
tanks where the people are footing the
bill control is affected mainly through
stock ownership and interlocking
directorates as indicated by senator
Metcalf study in 1978 it's rather
difficult for any of us to believe
there's any competition taking place
between two corporations that share
different directors or common directors
other corporations the study done by
Medcalf only concerned the top 130
corporations in the United States but I
will mention these these 130
corporations had assets in excess of an
excess of about 1 trillion dollars or
roughly 25% of all assets in the United
States and the industrial financial
utility retail diversified financial
broadcasting sectors these 130
corporations had five hundred and thirty
direct interlocks and over 12,000
indirect interlocks with each other
Frank now the top 13 corporations in the
study were ATM t Bank America sit Corp
which is first national city of New York
Chase Manhattan Prudential Metropolitan
Exxon manufacturers Hanover JP Morgan
General Motors mobile Texaco and Florida
each of the top 13 companies reached an
average of 70% of the other major
companies for a total of 240 and over
6,000 indirect interlocks this does not
include any interlocks between their
subsidiaries either given is there about
12,000 or more exactly to give an
example Bank America which is the
biggest US banking company interlocked
with the next biggest bank state Corp
Chase Manhattan JP Morgan and with the
two biggest insurance companies
Prudential and Metropolitan Life Bank
America's total 163 interlocks reached
75 at the top 130 corporations sit
corporation or First National City sit
Bank as they like to be called the
second biggest US banking concern and
also the biggest international or
multinational banking concern
interlocked with the top banks and
insurance companies Plus having 21 links
with AT&T 7 links with Exxon 12 links
with General Motors 3 with Ford 9 with
mobile for a total of 716 interlocks
reaching 97 at the top 130 corporations
Chase Manhattan which is another
multinational banking concern reached 89
of the top corporations through 535
interlocking directorates JPMorgan are
locked with ninety nine of the top
corporations through 533 interlocks and
so on it went President Franklin
Roosevelt said in 1933 the real truth of
the matter is as you and I know
so the large financial element and the
large centers has owned the government
ever since the days of Andrew Jackson
now the analogous situation not
analogous but the kind of sister
proposition with interlocking directors
seems to be stock ownership banks
insurance companies universities pension
funds are your major trust of common
stock owners and stock ownership is the
second door sister proposition to
interlocking directorates as a means of
control in the Medcalf study JP Morgan
subsidiary Morgan Guaranty and Trust
Company is the major identified stock
voter in 27 of the top 122 corporations
in the nation and is among the top five
stock voters in 56 corporations second
in stock voting power was first national
city's subsidiary sip bank which was the
major identified stock for voter in
seven corporations and among the top
five and 25 others Morgan Guaranty and
Trust is stock voter number one in four
of its New York sister banks ed Corp
manufacturers Hanover chemical Bankers
Trust as well as Bank of America
Corporation and I think I've read
recently in some papers that we have
intensely fierce competition between
Chase Manhattan first national city for
banking services in New York City I
think this is rather absurd particularly
since they're both Rockefeller family by
both founded by Rockefellers one by
William and one by JD in turn sit Corp
is stock voter number one and Morgan
guarantees parent holding company JP
Morgan & Company stock voter number two
in JP Morgan companies Chase Manhattan
stock voters number three and four and
JP Morgan & Company or manufacturers
Hanover trust and so on it goes and
without in other words that the the
banks which have the main stock holdings
and all these big corporations and have
the great amount of interlocking
directors to the other corporations they
are also interlocked with each other and
on each other right these are some of
the things that we can expect from
interlocking directorates and also from
this close-knit family of stock
ownership monopoly and destruction of
competition the ability to price fix the
ability to raise prices control over
resources control over markets export of
jobs businesses control over the
economic system in the political system
centralization and decision
in collusion undermining democracy
reciprocal dealing mergers restrictions
on new business fields the blocking of
expansion in the competitive fields and
with financial institutions that as a
core we have non-competitive coordinated
action and extending credit and
providing capital the ability to control
development and direction of the entire
American economy through this
interlocking web of stock ownership and
interlocking directors now it's the head
people in these organizations that are
also in the Bilderbergers a trilateral
commission and the Council of Foreign
Relations and what this report points
out is that these organizations are
interlocked themselves through
interlocking directorates and also
through stock ownership the mayor of New
York City in 1922 had a pretty clear
idea of who controlled whom the real
menace of our republic is the invisible
government at the head is a small group
of banking houses generally referred to
as international bankers this little
coterie virtually runs our government
for their own selfish ends the bike owns
the baler down City Hall the bank owned
the governor combined a No
bankers in the Senate can everybody
now's Ronald Reagan cultivate before it
blows his nose from the Washington Post
he's right
run by the blacks the Morgan Rockefeller
mr. dill upon your soul
is all by you
taking countries
for a showdown you will try we can't let
you
thank you
thank you
mr. banker thank you
banker
you
you
this world is run run by the banks
this world is robbed run by the banks
here's what Thomas Jefferson had to say
about the banks I believe that banking
institutions are more dangerous to our
liberties than standing armies already
they have raised up a money aristocracy
to set the government at defiance the
issuing power should be taken from the
banks and restored to the government to
whom it properly belongs let's assess
now the structure and role of the mass
media in society we turn to one of
America's most outstanding mass media
critics professor and author Noam
Chomsky he's the co-author of
manufacturing consent if you have a
society in which the voice of the people
is heard you got to make sure that that
voice says the right thing in
totalitarian societies it's not a big
problem
you got a club in your hand and if
people don't behave the right way you
hit them with a club or threaten them
with it so it doesn't really matter much
what they think what matters is what
they do and that you control by force
but as the capacity of the state to
control by force erodes it's necessary
to control what people think and in fact
I think you find much more sophisticated
concern for thought control precisely as
the society becomes more free I don't
think it's surprising that the
sophisticated discussion things like the
public relations industry and the
academic side of it and you know the
journalistic side and all this kinds of
things have been sampling I suspect if
one did a comparative study you'd find
that they develop primarily in
relatively free societies ours is a very
free society in the sense that the state
has by comparative standards very
limited resources to control by force
and I think it's undoubtedly in fact the
most sophisticated in the terms of in
the reliance on technique
of indoctrination and control public
relations industry in particular as a
American creation well coming up to more
modern times in the post Second World
War period carry fun again deep concern
over the need to control and deceive the
public to control the public mind
presidential historian Thomas Bailey
wrote in 1948 at the time when we were
sort of setting off on a new war that
cold war he wrote because the masses are
notoriously short-sighted and generally
cannot see danger until it's at their
throats our statesmen are forced to
deceive them into an awareness of their
own long-run interests deception of the
people may in fact become increasingly
necessary unless we're willing to give
our leaders in Washington a freer hand
and in 1981 as the United States was
launching a new crusade for freedom
Samuel Huntington the Fester of
Government at Harvard said in a private
but published discussion and interchange
you may have to sell intervention or
other military action in such a way as
to create the misimpression that it is
the Soviet Union that you're fighting
that's what the United States has been
doing ever since the Truman Doctrine
which is quite accurate and gives a
certain insight into the nature of the
Cold War in particular into the nature
of the war against Nicaragua which is
what he specifically had in mind well
what is the relationship of the mass
media to the Bilderbergers Trilateral
Commission and Council on Foreign
Relations the establishment media tell
us that they are the watchdogs of the
system that they are looking at it and
telling us everything there is and don't
worry folks if there's anything of
significance we'll let you know well
there's a study about various elite
newspapers and their directors
participation in these organizations and
as you see here the Council on Foreign
Relations the Bilderbergers and the
committee for economic development all
top elite organizations have very
definite number a good number of links
with these newspapers the Business
Roundtable Committee on present danger
foreign policy
the Association Ad Council the Chamber
of Commerce etc the directors of these
top American establishment newspapers
also participate in these organizations
as we can see all of the links with the
elite organizations add up to 100 in
other words 100 directors on these
establishment newspapers do participate
in the elite cartel ruling cartel
organizations well what about the
Bilderbergers here's a chart maybe a
little confusing but chart that shows
the top establishment publications such
as the New York Times and all and it
shows the participation in the
Bilderbergers from 1955 on now each one
of these numbers indicates there was one
participant of a particular type during
the particular specified years so we can
see there was a lot of participation in
the Bilderbergers from these various
publications but did you see anything
written about it very very little and
absolutely nothing on the television
networks here's a continuation of that
same chart from 1971 through 1978 now
notice there are only about half of the
years represented there the list of the
participants has not been recovered for
these other years so we really don't
know undoubtedly it would be
considerably greater number of people
participating but as you can see from
this chart the same publications
participate year after year mostly
people high in authority in the
newspapers particularly for the
television networks there are a few
trusted people but now you can see the
totals which add up to 51 people in the
Bilderberg organization who are from the
mass media but do they tell you all
about this important organization seldom
very very seldom here we can see the
participation in the trilateral
commission and it's the same story the
same organizations the same high
executives and directors participating
so how about that watchdog which dog are
they watching anyway they're certainly
watching the trilateral commission the
Bilderbergers and the Council on Foreign
Relations but they're sure not reporting
on them the media are part of the power
structure just like the other
organizations we've been talking about
their societal purpose is to inculcate
and defend the economic and social and
political agenda of the privileged
groups that dominate the domestic
society and they do this in all sorts of
ways they do it by selection of topics
by distribution of concern by the way
they frame issues by filtering of
information by emphasis and tone by
simple fabrication sometimes but
crucially by the bounding of debate to
make sure that it doesn't go outside of
certain limits the bounding both in the
news columns and in the opinion columns
because of course the news columns
themselves embody all sorts of
assumptions and ideological
presuppositions and so on there are a
whole set of mechanisms that legitimate
some opinions and make other opinions
seem far out or not worth studying the
mass media do this to my studies the
mass media I find that once this policy
has been set that the media will follow
up on this and you will not find any
discussion on anything on the other side
of this preset agenda by these people
you're talking about or if it is
discussed it's highly criticized but
generally it's just ignored to the
extent that there is a liberal bias it
serves primarily to bound thinkable
thought that is to instill the
unchallengeable assumptions which in
fact reflect this rather narrow elite
consensus so the liberal bias performs a
real function it says thus far and no
further
on as far as you can go and I go as far
how far I go is still accepting the
basic presuppositions as unchallengeable
now within those bounds there's ample
controversy and it reflects the tactical
divisions among elites over how to
achieve generally shared aims but these
limits are very
early transcended so the media thus
function in accordance with what my
co-author had read her Minh and I have
called a propaganda model in a recent
book that's another view well the
property a Buganda model has a lot of
predictions as a lot of predictions
about how the press is going to behave
but it also has a further prediction the
further prediction is that no matter how
well confirmed the propaganda model is
it cannot be taken seriously and
therefore must be effectively excluded
from mainstream discussion and that
actually follows from the model itself
the reason is that the model if you
think it through the model rejects
certain principles that are serviceable
to power that is it falls outside the
spectrum defined by the presupposition
that the media are adversarial and
cantankerous perhaps excessively so now
that presupposition is a useful one it's
serviceable to the interests of
established institutions to believe that
what you're reading is actually
criticism if it's in fact support that's
a technique it's a sophisticated
technique of indoctrination and of
course it's very serviceable to the
media themselves it's nice to think that
you're you know pride yourself on being
an independent that courageous adversary
of power and since those assumptions are
serviceable they're going to be upheld
according to the propaganda model and
those serious challenge will be
permitted notice here I'm talking about
what some might call the agenda-setting
media the media that set the frame that
others adapt to and that's pretty narrow
group it's primarily the New York Times
in the Washington Post and the three
television channels and a couple of
others it's not much else those set the
framework that everyone else pretty well
adapts to within anything like the
mainstream so we're talking about the
agenda-setting media and ask yourself
what they are well what they are is very
large corporations in fact they're
integrated with often owned by even
larger conglomerates now like other
businesses they have a product that they
sell to a market
the market is advertisers other
businesses and the product is audiences
the media don't finance themselves on
their audiences in fact the audiences
are usually a loss the more you
subscribe the more the newspaper loses
money and of course that television set
you know they might anything when you
turn it on they make their money from
advertisers advertising rates go up if
you have a the right kind of audience
and suddenly a relatively privileged
audience raises advertising rates so
what the media are just as an
institution is major corporations
selling relatively privileged audiences
to other businesses well what would you
expect to come out of such a system you
expect to come out something that
reflects the interests of the sellers
the buyers and the product wouldn't be
very surprising in fact it would be
amazing if it weren't true quite apart
from that there are many other things
pressing in the same direction there are
after all centers of power in the
society
the state the corporate sector others
and they can impose punishments for
things go wrong and we will offer
rewards if things go right you gain by
adapting to them it's less costly and so
on furthermore the top managerial
positions in the media editors and
colonists and so on if you make it into
those positions you're part of the
privileged elite quite at the very top
in fact but since you're both
journalists what do your evaluation of
the mass media and all these stories
we've been talking about you know the
way they operate is is is that they're
going to follow the leader you know
they're going to go with what the
official story in Washington is so many
times and what somebody some government
official hands them a document and it's
very rare that you get independent
digging and touche most of most
journalists are not investigators
they're stenographers they go to the
press conference they find out what the
the the official opinion is and they
might get some some balancing quotes
from from some from a dissenting view
and that that's the extent of the
investigation to go out and actually
independently analyze what the what the
real situation is who's pulling the
strings where the money went these
questions go virtually unasked and as
long as they dominate the debate their
setting has set the agenda the debate
remains in a fairly narrow framework and
is just not widely discussed in the mass
population I liken it to sort of a
puppet show this is the way I look at
the way the media and you've got a
puppet show here the puppets are dancing
and they're making shadows on the wall
and what the public gets is a reporter
sitting audience describing the shadows
on the wall that's sort of what we get
what's really happening is the shadows
of the wall are being made by puppets
for being manipulated by puppeteers who
are being told what to do by the puppet
master behind the curtain you know and
and that's the way I kind of look at it
and you know what we need to do is find
the puppet master you know and describe
how it all works instead of just
describing the shadows on the wall and
somehow I think that's the way the
government works too
the real rulers in Washington are
invisible and exercised power from
behind the scenes Felix Frankfurter
Supreme Court justice
you're watching alternative views
spotlighting the u.s. power structure we
turn now to elections free and fair
elections are cornerstones of democracy
are they controlled like the rest of our
political institutions Americans are
used to thinking or is a power structure
we wouldn't even be allowed to be in
politics but in America you're allowed
to run for president you can run for
anything you want there's just one thing
you better have several million dollars
or access to people that that have
several million dollars so you see we
can say in the one L is very fair
anybody can run but in fact not anybody
can when you get down to the specifics
of the matter so we have a formally open
and liberal system but in practice the
way things work out is that the rich get
richer and they are able to continue a
set of policies that that maximize their
advantages it is also the case but we
can see it we can all name some that
there are elected officials in the
United States who are not part of the
power lead and they very often do oppose
their position so I have no doubt there
are pro-labor there are
pro-environmental there are very liberal
elected officials at various levels in
our society and that does create then
real conflict so that my point would be
it's not that there aren't such people
there my point is they usually lose just
as you say with the new in effect if we
look at the FCC or if we look at the FTC
if we look at various kinds of attempts
to create for instance the Consumer
Protection Agency with some teeth or
what happens is the oceans that we that
we eventually lose they grind us down
and they grind us down because they have
this institutional base behind them
have more staying power the American
people been conditioned that it's great
to have two parties we don't want to be
like Italy where there's all these
choices we want to limit our choices
it's easier that way and we don't want
to be like Soviet Union where there's
only one party yeah that's right so they
have to but if policies never change
what's the difference so we do have one
party there's policies never change but
you could easily have two conservative
parties here that might compete for
years with steadily diminishing voter
turnout I mean this is after all what
happened the 70s right I mean that voter
turnout just goes down down down and the
sort of normal Democratic voter didn't
get a message
don't worry about whether you're voting
for Democrats or Republicans both of
them are controlled by industry the
personalities are different Nixon is
different from McGovern but the policies
that you'll get will be exactly the same
we came in by buses that delegates an
enormous convoys and the buses has
returned into the stockyard there was a
huge sign that said sheep them cattle to
the right hogs and goats to the left and
of course we followed the sheep and
cattle as soon as I arrived I knew what
it was like to be a cow in the in
Chicago and he walked into a pen and you
couldn't get out it was a feeling of
brutality that's before there was any
demonstration in the streets and before
there was any real trouble it was clear
that the government was frightened it's
as close as I've ever gotten into the
Berlin wall in the United States they
were trying to keep the people or
something coming emanating from the
United States out of this area
it was the professional fencing himself
in so they could carry on this game they
were all being led like sheep to the
slaughter in their own private opinion
the brutality of it was what struck me
powerfully and the there was an
overriding sense that the old human
voice could be raised again
this successful it is a is a show it's a
piece of fear
it's rehearsed in advance and it takes
place on tonight real walk in American
elections is not voters it is major
investor well the golden rule those who
have the gold rule if we look at the
history of any politician any politician
in America that rises to the very top
that what we find is that a certain
point in their career they become very
involved with the people that we're
talking about here and that and that the
upper class becomes essential to that
politician in terms of the financing of
his or her campaigns and that means
things like financing their travel
giving them money in advance so they can
schedule all their television time
giving them the kind of money that
allows them to hire experts and
basically then it gives any politician
that gives it gets involved with these
people a leg up structurally it seems to
me what's happened is the high cost of
the high cost of Technology and and the
access to television running for
president and running for Congress and
running for any office has caused both
parties to be penetrated and overwhelmed
by large contributors now both parties
rely a lot on small contributors but the
small contributors don't get any access
to the candidates the large contributors
do and these politicians are not going
to have a set of policy stances that are
going to be a nickel to to the ruling
group
we have a vote but no choice without
which we have no voice republic ellas or
rocket Kratts are all controlled by the
same fat cats
we're fooled while they continue to
rejoice this establishment this party
that we have the single party state this
fraternity that runs this country that
has two chapters a Republican and a
Democrat one a little bit more liberal
than the other one one more conservative
representing them the big business
interests more directly that's the
Republicans in terms of their interests
that's the 18 but they always have the
b-team that they can run out a Jimmy
Carter when Richard Nixon makes the
nation too angry the nation gets too
riled at the Vietnam War something like
that this is where they produced Michael
Dukakis he's a team player to the
establishment in order to be accepted as
a presidential candidate he did homage
to the to the arms race he said
eventually that he would give
humanitarian aid to the Contras he would
consider it he said definitely he would
give military aid to El Salvador which
means he bought into all the principles
of the covert secret government of the
covert operations of the covert
manipulation of the world he was seeing
another song when he was trying to get
the Democratic nomination that's right
before his background was progressive
but he bought it they screened him into
the system they groomed him into the
system he was advised that he could run
but if he would so what he was there is
he if the nation had clung had its
outrage had been sufficient over the
iran-contra scandal they had Dukakis
standing by the b-team to their interest
and he would give them some grief by
spending some money on housing and on
medical insurance for people and things
like that which is not their choice of
the way to invest the money they want to
invest it in missiles and things where
they make greater profits but he would
support the arms race and he would
support the CIA and the corporate
establishment the National Security
States activities but then they realized
they did not have to go
with the b-team the people didn't care
they didn't have to give the nation of
b-team so they went ahead and went with
the 18 which was George Bush ie they
concluded eventually that they could
Teflon eyes Bush despite all of this
incredible activity and selling to the
nation and they did we do have a
pluralistic society but we do not have a
pluralistic economic and political
structure I think that's excellent I
think that we I think we have the
paradox over the last 20 years that a
lot of the social movements would have
happened a lot of the events have made
in some way in some ways this is a very
open society at the individual personal
a kind of level and yet I continue to
believe we have the same corporate power
structure and I don't think it's
necessarily a contradiction in terms
that that my access to certain kind of
information my right to do things as an
individual which is a very important
part of liberalism that that could be
increased in the society and it has been
for for minorities for women for gays
for handicapped those kinds of liberal
individual freedoms could actually be in
some way increased and we could still be
relatively powerless